norbert vert bonjour
bonjour alors on ne vous entend pas pour
le moment
bienvenue en tout cas sur la matinale de
rtl france l'autriche impose donc lobby
l'obligation d'être vaccinés ou guérir
pour accéder au restaurant à la culture
on disait pourquoi les autorités
estiment que le test pcr n'est plus
aujourd'hui suffisant
je pense c'est dans l'octave
les non vaccinés
je leur talent pour le non vaccinés
c'est un but politique et acquittés
augmentent et les vaccinations
et est ce que la mesure est bien
l'accueillir en autriche où est ce qu'il
ya un déficit de vaccination on l'a dit
on n'a pas encore c'est seulement
quelques jours qu'on sait qu'on
connaissait ces nouveaux mesures mais en
principe il y a
peut-être les grandes compagnies qui
annule l'air leurs festivités de noël
mais son ca si vous voulez la population
accepte parce qu'on a six ans sur 100000
habitants qui sont nouveaux infectés et
c'est la limite et hôpitaux au conseil
du tourisme est très important en
autriche est ce que tous les vaccins
utilisés dans le monde sont considérés
comme comme valide
non seulement les vaccinations ils sont
acceptés et appliquent pas l'ema les
autorités européennes vous venez avec
son unique savons rien mais le spoutnik
est autorisée en première injection mais
il faut au moins une injection arn c'est
ça la règle
oui c'est correct donc il faut pour
avoir le pas salutaire il faut au moins
une piqûre de avec un vaccin accepté 1
heure
alors on le disait un rebond fort du
taux de contamination 9300 nouveaux cas
vendredi comment est-ce que vous vous
expliquez vous ce rebond en tant qu
infectiologues
oui d'abord il y a beaucoup de thé
speisser donc si vous voulez
l'augmentation sais c'est à cause des
espèces terres
qui sont partout chaque mot chaque coin
on peut faire tester psr l'autre
situation c'est que on pense que au
moins
ma 90% des gens qui comptent hospitalisé
un sont pas vaccinés et
la population accepte ce problème de
d'hospitalisation et du coup évidemment
il y a des problèmes de saturation dans
les hôpitaux comme on le voit d'ailleurs
un peu partout quand les personnes ne
sont pas vaccinés
tas de l'hôpital en autriche oui les
hôpitaux sont de limites surtout les
intensity lyonnais donc les gens
moi les morts on avait on l'avait
jacques si une
voire deux
deux cas dans les hôpitaux donc la
population à cette journée aux limites 1
quelle est la situation des soignants en
autriche est ce que il ya un ras-le-bol
comme on peut le voir dans d'autres pays
en europe je pense notamment en france
est ce qu'il y a des revendications
particulières des difficultés face à la
pandémie de kobe de 19
dans différents hôpitaux ils ont fermé
quelques lits même des sachets complète
parce qu'on n'a pas assez d'infirmières
et infirmiers
à cause de quoi
en principe ce tte la durée de
[Applaudissements]
d'être à l'hôpital et prolongé donc les
nouveaux cas sont sur les stations
intensif aux deux ou trois semaines
donc on a beaucoup moins capacité à
propos de la longue durée à des gens ce
temps les hôpitaux qui sont montrent
qu'ils sont pas vaccinés donc là vous
parlez d'aidés soignants qui ne sont pas
vaccinés donc il ne veut qu'ils ne
viennent plus travailler bonjour je
parle des malades mais quand on sonne y
aura
évidemment
c'est pas comme en france en france où
pour pouvoir travailler
dans les hôpitaux il faut avoir un pass
impasse
sanitaires
c'est pas pareil ici à une très grande
partie des infirmières et infirmiers 1
refuse de des taxis donc le prochain
passera probablement
que tous les gens qui vont au travail
sont vaccinés ou ou guéris le chancelier
s'est exprimé sur ces mesures avec ces
mots je le cite personne ne veut diviser
la société mais c'est notre
responsabilité de protéger la population
de notre pays comment réagit justement
la population à ces nouvelles mesures
vous lisiez à des personnels soignants
qui ne sont pas vaccinés qui refuse
d'être vacciné aujourd'hui pour aller
travailler quel est l'état d'esprit
général de la population face à ces
nouvelles mesures qui débute aujourd'hui
ouais c'est une question qu'il faut
négocier mais il paraît que
les infirmiers mais refuse à une grande
partie des tracks signer on essaie de
faire une campagne de vaccination de
l'ambassade et pour la population et
pour les infirmiers
la plupart des médecins et vaccinés dans
certaines situations un peu un peu
curieuse merci beaucoup norbert vetere
d'avoir accepté de répondre à nos
questions ce matin en direct sur arte
france